so I'm a full-time recruitment
consultant it takes me an hour to get to
work it takes me now to get back from
work so I'm probably back home 6:30 7:00
p.m. how do I have time to do a podcast
[Music]
in answer you make time but there's a
few things that I've been doing that
I've probably learned over the past
month or so which have really helped so
I wanted to share so first things first
if you're starting a podcast and you're
working full time you have to do outside
of working hours then you're gonna have
to again it comes back to the wire why
are you doing it because there's gonna
be time when you get home from work and
you want to put your feet up watch
Netflix or whatever but if you want to
do this as well as your job then you're
gonna have to make the time so you have
to be organized that's the first thing
so what I've been utilized in which I've
only started doing and my friends have
told me for a while now to use sort of
Gmail and the Google Calendar which I've
been doing so when I've scheduled
conversations with potential guests and
I'm going to tell them about the podcast
why I'm doing those sorts of things
before we actually do a podcast episode
I'll send them a calendar invite and
make sure that's in my calendar I know
what I'm doing and yeah so that's the
first thing be organized just maximize
your time even when you're at work so
what I've been doing is before I
actually decide to do a podcast episode
with someone I always want to take five
minutes ahead of time to share with them
why am i doing this podcast they're
gonna be giving me their time so I
wanted to understand what's in it for
them
one doing there and I've been doing that
quite a lot at the time at work on my
lunch break so utilise the time that you
do have so when you aren't working you
you've eaten your lunch instead of
scrolling through your face but your
Instagram feed organized some calls with
other people that you know that you want
to get in your guests tell them about
your podcast etc so be organized and
maximize your time and the last thing to
just note is when you've got a really
strong wine and you actually enjoy what
you're doing in terms of the podcast
what you're speaking about it should be
easy
it does feel easy for me to go home
after a long day and to prepare for a
podcast or do a podcast episode because
I enjoy it so if you're feeling a lot of
resistance to can't be bothered tonight
whatever think about why you're doing
there you sure you're doing it for the
right reason
[Music]